over the last week or two I have asked
all of the sources I get to speak to the
Insiders that work within the industry
what is their opinion about what is
going to happen with Stargate in 2024
what are their
predictions and I got a
consensus welcome to Sidra your SciFi TV
and movie channel so I think it's fair
to say we know Amazon was going to
announce a movie at San Diego ComicCon
sidre actually started talking about
this well over a year ago but to be
honest a few insiders and even a couple
of actors have come out and basically
confirmed ever since we are as close as
near as damn it certain they were going
to announce this is San Diego ComicCon
now there's been lots of problems along
the way we've heard rumors about
directors being approached and
potentially even being signed on we've
heard rumors about a script bouncing
around around and I've actually spoken
to people who have seen versions of that
script We Believe Mark Fergus is still
involved even though we're not 100%
certain we think they might have even
started actual preparations for filming
in Eastern Europe and actually the
original plan was that this was going to
be filmed in Eastern Europe and a lot of
the special effects done in Germany we
think that maybe has changed now because
by the time Amazon are actually going to
be able to film this they will actually
have Studio capacity in the USA to be
able to do it something they simply
wouldn't have had last summer so as time
has gone on Amazon has evolved its plan
but what is that plan now what can we
actually expect in 2024 and what are all
my sources saying they think is going to
happen first of all is it possible we'll
get a January announcement well of
course it is at the end of the day
Amazon could now decide to um announce
this anytime that their ducks are all in
a row we have always said on this
channel they are going to want a main
actor which we don't think they have
they're going to want a director which
we think they might have they need a
script obviously and we think they have
that too but also from a business point
of view they physically need somewhere
to film it and we think they'll have
that by the summer so the announcement
really could come any time they could
just put that press statement out boom
Stargate is coming back alongside things
like RoboCop Legally Blonde etc etc
because guys you've got to remember
Amazon haven't actually announced any
major MGM projects since they've took
over 18 months ago MGM was in a bit of a
state they've basically now absorbed MGM
into Amazon pictures they have
restructured the business completely
they fired a bunch of people they've
hired a bunch of people all of of that
work we believe has now been done but it
did take a long time we believe RoboCop
is coming it's not been announced
Legally Blonde 3 has actually been in
development now for nearly two years and
we've had no update and obviously that's
the film we're most excited about on
this channel now MGM spent over8 billion
doar to buy the name of MGM they want
MGM in their title they want the respect
having MGM in their title brings them
they want the respect of other Studios
but they also want all of that lovely IP
all of those movies that MGM has made
over the years that they now have access
to remembering we haven't even had an
announcement on bond the most valuable
thing MGM owns so don't stress that we
haven't had a Stargate announcement yet
but is a January announcement actually
possible well in a video a couple of
months ago I told you you that MGM plus
and the head of MGM plus Mite actually
does believe and have been basically
promised a series for MGM plus he's been
arguing that they desperately need
something like a Stargate series for
ages if they want to grow MGM plus as a
streaming service of streaming platform
and a new series like that would really
be their main show that would be the
thing that they would advertise like mad
that would be the thing that drives
growth and they've been arguing that for
the last 18 months now we've been
telling you as I said that Amazon seemed
to want to do a movie first but I can
actually tell you in a minute that there
has been a little bit of movement and I
am hearing a rumor that we might get
something quite interesting that might
be much sooner than the movie but I'll
tell you about that in a minute and that
as I say MGM plus believe they have a
promise verbally that they will get that
series eventually I don't don't think
that will be this year but if it is it
will be on the MGM development slate
that is released at the end of January
or early February that is basically when
MGM plus releases information about all
of the stuff that they're going to be
doing over the next 12 months so if they
have actually got Amazon to agree to
series and they're going to be allowed
to have that Series in the next 12 to 18
months it will be on that slate and we
will get that January announcement we're
looking forward to do I think it's
likely not really if you enjoy the
channel and you want to support us more
go and check out the description where
there's links to all of the other citrex
stuff including links to our partner
YouTube channels like Matt's nerd Corner
stormy Channel Harris's mcubed also
though don't forget to drop us a thumbs
up and a comment all of these things
help us with YouTube and those pesky
little algorithms and they help spread
the channel even further
oh and don't forget to subscribe so when
do I think we will get an announcement I
think it will be at San Diego Comic Con
in June 2024 and actually when I've
spoken to my sources 14 out of 15 agreed
with me that it's most likely that they
will delay until San Diego ComicCon even
though some of them agree we may get
some sort of statement before then we
may get some sort of just basically a
press release online saying we're
developing RoboCop Stargate blah blah
blah they may do that but at San Diego
Comic Con we will get a properly a big
announcement actors on stage all of that
sort of thing that's really what they
hoped to do back June 2023 and that is
going to be the Target because Stargate
will be a big deal for Amazon obviously
bond is number one but really Stargate
is number two so if they can do that and
do that big announcement Sano Comic Con
they will so what is the little bit of a
surprise I mentioned earlier in the
video well as I say MGM have been
arguing that they want a TV series the
whole way through and I said to you um
three or four months ago now there was a
big meeting just towards the end of the
strikes where Amazon said okay come on
tell us everything why do you think this
should be a series not a movie now I
said to you I don't actually know what
the result of that meeting was or that
discussion I don't know if Amazon went
ah all right then want to have a serious
or whether they want no movie but I do
hear rumors the rumor is actually that
Amazon did basically dismiss the
argument and said that you know no this
is going to be a movie first we've got
the budget for it we're going and we've
already done loads of work on it as well
we're going ahead but they conceded some
of the argument what Mite and the others
MGM plus were saying was that there's
been a big gap we need need something to
explain some of that gap before you go
into a movie and if we do that with a
series it will then make the movie way
more understandable and hopefully
underpin and give a foundation to its
success if they just do a film it's a
big risk so Amazon may have actually
conceded that point and there are
conversations right now about a
miniseries this is something that would
establish what has been happening over
the last few years the decade basically
of missing Stargate and that would set
up the movie that would then be followed
by a series now that is I think really
interesting especially considering if
you consider the timelines so what I'm
being told is the plan at the moment and
this hasn't been decided as far as I
know this is just what they're talking
about at the moment the miniseries would
be on our screens either the end of 2024
or the start of 2025 the movie would
actually start filming this summer and
would then take about 18 months to get
to the cinema so that would be probably
early 2026 maybe the winter of 2025 but
it would really depend on how much work
has already been done which we think
quite a lot has been done in
pre-production ETC getting stuff ready
and how big a grander scale a movie is
if this is a way more actor person
Driven movie and there isn't Mass loads
of special effects then that would bring
that date sooner so in that sort of
region a then full-blown proper TV
series would follow in
2026 that is what I'm predicting is
happening and to be honest the bulk of
the people I speak to agree that that is
a l ly and sensible prediction to
make I get to speak to people all of the
time now behind the scenes that do not
want to share their identities obviously
because it's their job at the end of the
day I actually do get to speak
occasionally to people that have worked
on Stargate that again have refused to
identify themselves and refused to speak
about Stargate on our Channel because
they hope to maybe get a job in the
future on Stargate and they don't want
to rock the boat I've actually got to
speak to two or three actors I
desperately tried to get to do
interviews on this channel and they
basically said I can't right now wait
until the announcements made and then
we'll talk again now that screams to me
that they know the things that we know
the things that we've been talking about
that this is the worst kept secret in
Hollywood this is being planned and they
hope to get a job out of it at the end
and do I blame them no of course not of
course they want to get involved in
something like this and I hope they do
so let's see what happens in the next
few months but we might still be waiting
a little longer than we wanted but guys
get into the comments and tell me what
you think what is your prediction for
what Amazon will finally do with
Stargate this is definitely going to
happen I would actually bet one of my
children on this it's going to happen
yes we've had delay after delay because
of the restructure of MGM and then the
act just strikes and the right to
strikes but there is really nothing once
Amazon has got its capacity up and
running with for Studio space this year
there is nothing stopping them from
finally doing
Stargate what do you predict though is
going to happen and what's the sort of
time frame you think is sensible get to
the comments and tell me exactly what
you think if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon /re which is
where most of our videos Premiere first
and you get to see them without the
adverts you lucky bunnies also go to
s.co where I write stories based on a
lot of our videos and I try to add a
little bit more information for you to
digest go and check it out and as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
[Music]
time